Mario and Luigi Mario
Luigi twitch chat can be downright
ruthless with their
roasts yo not the KCK Fu Panda look like
the fat kid from Deadpool this one's
actually good my dad came to my room and
asked if the car has been cleaned
without looking away from the screen I
just said some he just smiled and walked
away he knew it was washed okay but why
do you laugh John your receding hairline
isn't as bad as on camera
you got a Sean Hunter sort of thing
going shut the up I do not have
this nah those are my boys bro you bu
like a Toyota
Sienna ye new song literally describes
you bigger than everything y I'm about
to shut the stream off chat it feels
weird seeing the back of your head well
your mom sees it every night or let's
just just Bazinga bazinga